Cô này thì nội vì các bạn thì cú khú của bạn của các bạn ở đây
Thường thường đẹp hạc. Gọc cái bài cú ý thường đường đường đường đường đường đường đường đường đường đường đường đường đường đường đường đường đường đường đường đường đường đường đường đường đường đường đường đường đường luôn đó
Chưa bà này
Rồi đây này nhưng mà toàn thuần là bà hoộc chưa hiền cú
Duy nhìn lên vào người toàn nó kìm xét
4 năm sai, đặc biệt là kìm này mà bám là từng t đưa vào kìm việt
Trạc đầu chặp Kuy xuống tác nghiêm dọn khoảng
Nhưng này chết dễ say, ta này kỳ bầu trước n学 ka chết xấu rồi đúng lại
ở honor ngon nжi
chỗ lạc qen mất kể giả t jeśli đàn bọn nжi
nêm cục dễ say